national school choice week is a
celebration of charters private public
and even online education for kids and
their parents across the United States
as a part of the celebration reason TV's
editor-in-chief Nick Gillespie and
recent foundations director of education
and child welfare Lisa Snell gave a talk
at our Los Angeles headquarters calling
[ __ ] on public education abuses you
know the basic idea of why we need
school choice is the context is that our
current system is failing parents it's
failing taxpayers and especially it's
failing students it's filled with abuses
with waste with misdirected attention
and just kind of stupid motions that
aren't helping anybody and one of the
things that reason that we particularly
are interested in talking about is that
it's out of step with what at Reason
magazine and on reason.com
in our videos reason TV videos we talked
about as the libertarian moment which we
we say is a turn to hyper personalized
and individualize goods and services and
everything in our lives except for a few
places education is one of them health
care is one of them retirement is one of
them the problem in a nutshell is that
going back to say 1970 and you could you
could you know go back a little bit less
or a little bit longer the trend is the
same we have seen again and again the
cost in inflation-adjusted terms to
educate somebody from K through 12 has
gone up from in 1970 in current dollars
it cost about 57,000 dollars for all
those years of education for 13 years of
education per student it currently costs
her in 2010 it costs a hundred and sixty
four thousand dollars in inflation
adjusted terms and these lines down here
are assessments that have been constant
over that same period for graduating
high school seniors they are flat or
slightly declining so we are essentially
paying about two and a half times more
for the same product and one thing to
know or one thing to think about is how
awful like there isn't another thing in
your life probably where you are getting
a 1970 quality good or service for two
and a half times what it was we said
we're calling [ __ ] on abuses in
public edge
ocation you can fill you know endless
days just everyday in the newspaper
there are ridiculous stories here are
some case studies and you know abuses of
students or of the educational system so
one of them which we did a video about a
buffalo teachers got nine million
dollars in taxpayer purchased plastic
surgery in 2009 and it was 5 million it
went after 5 million dollars in 2012
they're trying to phase out the problem
but this is amazing and it's part of
their union contract Detroit teachers
called a sick out over building
conditions despite they have a per pupil
spending of in the Detroit School
District of eighteen thousand dollars
per student they got because of the the
problems with their buildings they got a
seventy five hundred dollar grant this
year to add per student and yet forty
four hundred dollars of that is going to
go to debt service and retirees so
they're still not going to be able to
actually adequately repair and maintain
their their physical plant for eighteen
grand a year per student plus new things
this is a picture from a school middle
school I believe in in Detroit where
kids are playing indoors because the
neither the gin the hallways because the
gym and the playgrounds aren't
functional you know this is just it's
abuse there's no way around it an eleven
year old was suspended for bringing heat
he was supposed to bring a plant into
school like a leaf for a project he
brought in this picture down here which
hopefully those of you who are a
converse and will recognize that this is
not a pot leaf it's a Japanese maple
leaf he brought it in he was an honor
student which may not mean much because
everybody's an honor student these days
but it was mistaken for pot the school
district tested it and they still effect
you know when they found that it was not
a pot leaf but they still suspended him
for a year his parents had to fight to
get him back in the school and there's
an ongoing court case which is not yet
then adjudicated fully mandatory drug
tests for choir and academic challenge
honor students this is a Supreme Court
case that was settled in 2002 which
legalized or or finally
said yeah you know what schools can as a
condition of taking part in
extracurricular activities and Antonin
Scalia was one of the the most forceful
writers of the majority opinion or a
concurrent opinion saying yeah you know
what schools have an absolute right to
force kids who want to do
extracurricular activities to submit to
mandatory drug tests
even though statistically and they all
have you know everybody acknowledged
this was true if you do extracurricular
activities you're less likely than the
average student to take drugs or drink
but it's still this is a condition the
girl who who you know brought this case
ultimately or was in her name
IRLS she was an honor student who was in
you know in the choir and I had never
had a problem never tested positive for
anything and an academic challenge was
just like a quiz show it's like jeopardy
it's at the ultimate nerd sport but she
has to and and this is still going on my
I have a son who goes to high school in
Ohio and we just got word because he
does sports you know you have to submit
to man you know mandatory random drug
tests it's horrible and then finally
just to kind of run through these
quickly there's the great pop top pop
tart freak out of 2013 in Maryland which
resulted in suspension counseling
reinstatement and then a sad new law in
Florida which we'll get to in a second
but some of you might have followed this
case a kid at lunch he chewed his gun
this is a this is an artist rendition he
did not do such a good job yeah but he
had a pop-tart
he had a pop-tart that he made into a
gun by eating part of it and then he was
like going bang bang two kids at the
table so he got kicked out it took
forever for him to get reinstated then
Florida legislators actually passed this
law in 2014 which among other things
says that you won't get in trouble for
simulating a firearm or weapon while
playing including brandishing a
partially consumed pastry or other food
item to simulate a firearm are welcomed
and that's just sad as an
so before we continue I'm going to ask
for please show which one is your
favorite by clapping which is your
favorite abuse so we have some audience
participation is it Buffalo teachers get
plastic surgery is that your great
outrage Detroit Public Schools can't
maintain buildings okay not a lot of
fans for that one
Virginia kid suspended for Japanese
mapley thank some of that drug test for
choir girls not a lot and assaults with
deadly but breakfast pastries alright
there's like dad it's good that did well
if not absolutely one and I want to talk
a little bit more about pop-tarts before
I turn it over to to Lisa to talk about
education and the reason why I talk
about pop-tarts is because this is to
get to that idea about the libertarian
moment or about the profusion of choices
in in our lives that matter they allow
us to be who we are man ludwig von mises
once said the great Austrian economist
said that man is the choosing animal and
you know more choices it's it's better
the more choice the better and all sorts
of things and I'd like to use pop-tarts
as a kind of a metaphor for what's
happened in America over the past 40 or
50 years in particular in 1964 pop-tarts
were produced by Kellogg or were
introduced to by Kellogg it was a joke
on pop art which was popular at the time
people like red looked and rode looked
and seen and Andy Warhol and whatnot
there were four flavors originally
blueberry strawberry brown sugar
cinnamon and Apple current which faded
pretty quickly but they all looked the
same and they bet you know they pretty
much tasted the same and what has
happened to pop-tarts over the past 50
years 45 50 years is that they have
grown into you know endless variations
of mutations this is what's happening to
our in our lives every day which is a
good thing currently there's something
like you know at any given time there's
about three dozen pop-tart varieties on
your grocery shelves how many of you
have kids or how many of you pop-tarts
on a regular basis okay whew
if you go down the aisle with pop-tarts
you'll see all different types and like
where you know it used to be America was
much more like this where you know you
know there was a very little variation
we talked about little variation maybe
there were there were whites and blacks
and that was about it but you know we
didn't we didn't talk a lot about
difference we didn't look a lot
different now we're much more like the
pop-tart world where there are more and
more varieties of every in everything
that you care about whether it's people
whether it's about goods whether it's
about services and pop-tarts are a great
way to talk about how change is
happening in America how there's more
choice how there is more kind of
independence and individualization of
everything a couple of years ago in 2010
pop-tarts Kellogg put a pop-up store in
in Times Square in New York and and that
the big draw there was a thing called
the pop-tart varieties or where it
allowed you to personalize your own
pop-tart and that's kind of like a nice
thing when you think about your work
life is radically different than your
parents or your grandparents work life
you probably set your own hours to some
degree or certainly more than you might
have or your ancestors might have in the
past which is a good thing even pop-top
the pop-tart celebrates freedom of
choice which is always a good thing and
so you know this is a way of thinking
about our world what is good about our
world or what is best about our world
and what we strive for is a world that
allows people to individualize and
customise their lives to the way they
want it to be and so here's just quick
examples of stuff up here in the corner
before he was a known as a sexual sex
addict Tiger Woods was once upon a time
was a very good golfer what was
interesting in the 90s when he emerged
he called himself a Kaplan Asian because
he he he said he didn't fit into
existing categories and he was part
Caucasian black Indian and Asian he was
a cab line Asian and that's also a
metaphor for who we are in America we
think about ourselves in much more
complicated sophisticated nuance terms
when Amazon came online in 1995 it
revels
not just the way we buy books but the
way we think about books I grew up in
New Jersey in the 70s and 80s and the
nearest bookstore was miles away and it
was smaller than this room I had had you
know virtually no choice the library was
a little bit better but there were
always like people who were your
neighbors who would look at what you
were checking out Amazon not only gave
us that anonymity but it also allowed us
to get any book we wanted and then use
books came online and suddenly even if
you lived in the middle of nowhere and
I've lived in a lot of small towns as an
adult you could get anything you wanted
it was you know personalized
individualized they give you suggestions
this is the have any of you done 23andme
do you know okay so this is a cheap
hundred dollar DNA test you can do you
can find your genetic code your genetic
sequence it's the ultimate who you are
23andme also is at the forefront of kind
of super individualized medicine in the
future and this is already happening and
it's an incredibly exciting and
liberating and and wonderful the idea
where you will you know in within or the
next 10 years we will be taking drugs
that are match to our own genetics in
order to be more effective because some
drugs work on some people and they don't
work on others and we're starting to
build towards individualized medicine
uber is the service that is everybody's
private driver how many of you have used
uber you know it's it's phenomenal right
I mean it's not only does it stop you
from driving drunk its UPS other people
from driving drunk and you can get to
wherever you are particularly you know
in places I lived in LA for three years
and LA has a terrible taxi system it's
it's really you know there aren't cabs
you can't hail them from the street
uber is a total GameChanger and then
especially in smaller cities but it's
private personalized service this thing
in the middle here is from shapeways
which is a 3d printing company you can
go online and you can get you could you
can get a bust of yourself you can send
them photos and get a 3d rendered bust
of yourself or of you know your husband
your wife your kids or whatever
you can personalize just amazing Italy
and then that's Facebook which now has
something on the order of 50 different
gender designations where we went from
50 years ago we talked about men and
women or we talked about male and female
and you know now we're in an age where
things are just exploding and
proliferating and that is you know to
bring it back to school choice and and
this concept of the libertarian moment
the libertarian moment broadly speaking
is and this is from an article I wrote
with Matt Welch my colleague and
co-author the editor-in-chief of Reason
magazine the libertarian moment is a
time of increasingly hyper
individualized hyper expanded choice
over every aspect of our lives it's a
it's a world where it's more possible
than ever to live your life on your own
terms it's and it's not perfect but it's
better than the status quo
it is never before has been easier for
more individuals to chart their own
course and steer their lives by the
Stars as they see the sky except in
certain places and one of those places
which is both where it's the most
glaring and the most important is
education the traditional you know
residential assignment public school
system is expensive and it is delivering
terrible results and that's bad if
you're a taxpayer it's bad if you're a
parent and it's really bad if you're a
kid you know who is bored or worse in
the school that you get sent to and now
I'm going to turn it over to Lisa who's
going to talk about the contours of that
and also how to fix it let's just start
with the Robert F Kennedy Community
School which was built on the site of
the old Ambassador Hotel and it cost
five hundred and seventy eight million
dollars and I was talking to Nick
earlier and he was telling me about in
his town the you know he was complaining
because it cost 12 million or 15 million
dollars that they had to build a new
high school when there was nothing wrong
with the old high school well in LA
Unified they've had a few different
multi-billion dollar bonds to build new
schools and now the problem is they're
having a difficult time finding kids to
actually fill those schools but the
Robert F Kennedy Community School
actually goes with the theory
that if you build it kids will learn
right so if you have lots of extras and
the kids feel safe and they feel like
it's a good space that they'll learn
turns out not so much that's not
necessarily true this is the teachers
lounge at the school and then that is
the theater at the school and they also
have I think sound rooms for
professional musicians and they have
kitchens for kids to cook in that rival
the food network and lots of cool stuff
really cool stuff at the school
basically in California we had what was
called an academic performance index
which aggregated both test scores and
other measures that and the bottom line
is you want your academic performance to
move up not down to be going into
positive numbers and so you can see that
most of these brand new schools that
were in this building their first couple
years of testing they had scores that
were going down the only exception is
the new open world Academy and that I
think was the only elementary school and
the elementary school was doing pretty
pretty well so 629 billion dollars and
I'm actually going to give a shout-out
to my colleague Aaron Smith because I
took and borrowed a few of his slides
from a presentation that he did and 314
million people 67 percent of them could
be arguably 15 to 65 keep going and then
so we each are paying $3,000 for public
education if you count every possible
person that could be working and so
basically between the 70 and this is
another way costs have gone up 131
percent I mean we can say this many ways
the costs are going up the quality has
stayed the same this is from the Cato
Institute Andrew Coulson actually wrote
like one of the best books in on market
education and then here this is an
interesting slide because this is
federal education spending and you can
see that federal education spending has
also gone way up not just regular
spending and again everything is flat if
you look at how much money do we spend
compared
to other countries we're at the very top
with Switzerland spending the most money
and the OECD actually did an interesting
study where and you can keep going where
they looked at how did student
achievement do compared to how much you
spend and so what they found is
countries high spending countries like
the United States basically performed
about the same as countries that spent
50% of what we spend and so here's an
example of that where the United States
is spending upwards of $12,000 per
student on average and here are our
performance this is 2012 reading and
math and this is against other countries
where our kids rank and then you look at
Estonia that spends considerably less
half of what we spend and they're
actually scoring higher than us on these
international exams and then the LA
School District elet the there was just
an article out that basically is
claiming that they will be broke by 2020
unless drastic steps are made and they
just actually have had a lot of turmoil
obviously in LA Unified that some of the
local people you may have read about
they just got a new superintendent there
is a plan in Los Angeles to basically
increase the number of charter schools
in the district
but even without increasing the number
of charter schools you can see that
since 2002 LA Unified has lost almost
200,000 kids and so that's a lot of
money at the same time that they were
opening brand new skills and building
schools and some of those kids moved out
of the city like other urban areas but a
lot of them move to charter schools and
so the charter schools on average in LA
their performance whether its graduation
rates or sending kids to college or
actual student achievement scores
especially for the most difficult and
intractable high school students which
it's always hard to get improvement with
high school students because you know
they want to not study and they'd rather
play video games and watch Netflix I
have a 17 year old and a 19 year old
so I know how it goes but the broad
foundation proposed a secret plan that
got leaked to the press and then got a
lot of news coverage where they would
spend money to put half of LA Unified
students in charter schools and then you
can see here's they they've had a lot of
protests about charter schools in Los
Angeles and at the Badri building we're
out the district there's like a tall
building with like 40,000 adults that
don't go to schools that actually work
in the building and they have a lot of
protest in front of that building and
they're always protesting this charter
school expansion this is where I wanted
to kind of get into like the expansion
of school choice in general right now we
have 59 school choice programs that
involve private school choice in the
country so ten years ago when I was
doing this basically there was one
voucher program in Milwaukee and so you
know that's considerable growth and
these include all kinds of different
school choice programs voucher programs
tax credit programs where you can
actually have education contributions
where you get the money based on your
own tax deductions education savings
accounts so we have a huge spectrum and
what I like to say is Marshall Fritz
really advocated for the separation of
church school in state sorry not church
and state school and state and you know
he had a group where he really believed
that homeschooling and private paying
and taking full responsibility and if we
think of like the pure libertarian
moment we would have a pure market based
education system where everyone took
care of their own kids problem with that
is the reality is that we have that six
hundred billion dollars in spending that
we already spend on public education and
you know as much as we wish that there
was some switch that we could flip that
everyone would be in a choice based and
everyone would take responsibility for
their kids that's not the system that we
have and so then we have a continuum of
different kinds of school choice
programs that are more or less regulated
by the government and so that includes
things like in the middle charter
schools where schools are
we have contracts with the government to
run schools and they have certain kinds
of fiscal and academic responsibilities
this is kind of a map by the Friedman
Foundation which they're big supporters
of school choice and they've marked kind
of where these different kinds of
programs are a lot of libertarians
really like tax credit programs where
either corporations or individuals take
a direct tax credit and then they fund
scholarships for kids to get go to
private schools and they feel like
that's a little bit less involvement and
then on the very far end of the spectrum
we actually have been working at The
Reason Foundation on an idea of public
school choice that we call backpack
funding or money following the child and
that would be more like how you would
think of higher education right now you
get in the whether you go to a public or
a private college you can take your
financial aid or your parents money with
you and nobody thinks about you having
to be residentially assigned I mean
everyone is competing state schools and
public schools like UC Berkeley are
competing down the street with private
schools like Stanford and we think that
is totally normal
but in public education we've accepted
the idea that where you live largely
still determines where you go to school
and people have normalized the idea that
you have to be residentially assigned
and so then what happens is people that
can choose with their real estate
choices and can afford to go to maybe
not the best school in America but a
relatively good school they use their
real estate choices to drive school
choice and then disadvantaged or kids
that don't have the opportunity to live
in a better neighborhood if they have
poor schools they just have to go there
real quick on the empirical outcomes of
school choice programs when you look at
and this is true actually for charter
schools as well when you look at kind of
the gold standard studies where they've
actually done random assignment and they
placed kids in voucher programs or
private school programs and public
school programs and compared to outcomes
there has been the
majority of the studies have positive
effects and that includes things like
academic outcomes for the kids that
choose schools but it also 22 studies
show that the competition leads to
positive academic outcomes for the kids
that remain in the public schools and
Carolyn Hawkes B who is a researcher in
the education movement
she always has said that competition
lifts all boats and education and
certainly at reason we in our public
school choice center where we look at
just public funding that follows the kid
within a district like Denver or
Hartford or San Francisco the minute
that you have incentives and the money
is attached to the kids even in a purely
public school system people start to
change their behavior and there's
positive outcomes but overall the
empirical outcomes for school choice
have been good and even when you hear
negative research about charter schools
if you look at the methodology the
better studies do show that charter
schools have improvements for kids and
specifically when you look in geographic
areas like New Orleans Los Angeles
Detroit where there's a mass of charter
schools and they have market share where
they're really competing with the public
schools they tend to outperform the
traditional schools the charter school
movement is where we've seen the most
growth in school choice there's been a
hundred percent growth since 2007 we
actually now have about 2.9 million
students in charter schools there 67
hundred charter schools in the United
States but 200 charter schools closed in
2015 and out of 67 hundred schools total
200 schools closing like that seems kind
of like a lot but it's actually a
feature of charter schools that if they
can't meet their fiscal obligations if
they can't meet their academic
obligations you can actually close a
school and you know people get upset
about well what about the disruption to
students but how disrupted as a student
that
has to go to a school that's been
failing for decades you know if you take
Centennial High School in Compton which
lost its accreditation like 20 years ago
it's one of the lowest performing
schools in the country decades of kids
have gone through that dysfunctional
school and it's not going to close so
that's a positive thing
charter schools really you know and
depending on how you feel about the
bubble and higher education and you know
college education but you know charter
schools have done something not only do
they show that they can teach kids to
read or do math better but they actually
are placing their students in college
and even though you know sometimes we're
skeptical about college
almost all the evidence still shows that
your lifelong outcomes in terms of
quality of life you know people stay
married longer if they have the college
education so maybe that's you know a
detriment I'm not sure it's you know
they you have earning potential that's
much larger you know this is something
that you know you don't see a lot of
urban traditional schools that are you
know bragging that a hunt even my kids
go to an upper-middle-class school and I
can guarantee you that a hundred percent
of the students are not going to college
and then we talked a little about a bit
about market share and I just want to
talk about New Orleans and use them as a
quick case study because New Orleans
after Hurricane Katrina in 2015 5
basically the whole school system shut
down and because a lot of local laws
they basically let all of the teachers
go and they were able to get out of the
union contract and they started from
scratch with a public school system and
now actually this year the last
traditional public school in New Orleans
closed and it's the only city in the
country where a hundred percent of the
kids pick customized schools that are
competing with each other and you know
you wonder why Detroit can't pay its
bills one of the reasons is 55 percent
of its students have left the district
to go to charter schools dc40 is
encroaching on 50 percent of its
students in charter schools so you have
these play
we're charter schools run by independent
operators are giving the district a real
run for its money in terms of both
individual choices for kids and the
academics and the quality of the schools
and then this is just snapshot of a
bunch of charter schools in New Orleans
all of those are different kinds of
schools that parents can choose from and
again one of the things about New
Orleans and about the charter school
movement is it gets rid of the
residential assignment requirement and
parents really can pick any school but
the point about that is not that you
want to bus people all over you know if
you have true neighborhood schools that
grow up near you and our high quality
you'll pick that school you don't
necessarily want to have to take three
buses and a train to get to a higher
quality school and unfortunately in some
urban areas kids have to go to the
suburbs or they have to go far away to
find good schools the point of
competition like New Orleans is now
everyone does have a higher quality
school than five years ago in their
neighborhood and every indicator really
shows that New Orleans is improving the
graduate rate went from fifty four
percent to seventy three percent fifty
one percent of the students are college
bound after high school and there's
typical improvement of eight to fifteen
percentile points on reading and math
test scores in New Orleans and actually
Tulane University which is the next
slide just did a big study and what they
found is that if you look this is
basically New Orleans down here on test
scores and this is other districts in
Louisiana and now in after 2012 New
Orleans is actually converged on all of
those other districts and they've
surpassed actually other Louisiana
districts in terms of their student
achievement the Tulane study found a
four percent effect size which is huge
in education studies and that's actually
just to give some context for that
universal preschool and pre-k class size
reduction where you have one teacher for
fifteen student
New Orleans actually has a much larger
effect size than a lot of the very
popular reforms that people say if we
just had preschool or if we just you
know had smaller classes for teachers
students would have improved they also
moved to the from the twenty-fifth
percentile to the 40th percentile on the
AC T which you know that's a pretty big
jump and then I just want to end with
education savings accounts because this
is really school choice 2.0 and it goes
more to kind of one way that we might
get to a really customized education
system and education savings accounts
are the idea that instead of getting a
voucher amount or a tax credit
scholarship that goes to one school in
the future maybe you want to you know
take some online classes from Stanford's
online high school or you want to go to
your local Community College and you
know take a couple classes there and
your kid needs a speech therapist and
you know there's all these different
needs that you have and instead of
thinking of like we have buildings and
we have funding and kids go there that
we actually would pay for kids to have
an educational experience throughout
their lifetime and that that would look
different for every kid and lots of kids
will still use their education savings
account which basically is state and
education local funds that go directly
to parents and they go into a bank
account and they can pay for education
services and then that money if they
actually are frugal and save money can
roll over to the next academic year and
maybe they want to spend more money on
high school than they do on second grade
or maybe they want to save it for higher
education so that they have a head start
to send their kids to college but that's
one way that education is moving this
whole ideas and Nevada actually passed
the first universal education savings
account and it actually is the first
universal school choice program in the
nation that applies to every single kid
so it's interesting that this new idea
of an education savings account and
basically every parent would get $5,000
in Nevada and they could use that for a
private school they could add their own
money to it they could use it for home
schooling materials for you know really
anything that the parent wants and again
the kids still have to you know move
along at grade level I think I don't
know there's not a testing requirement
and the education savings account at
this at this point I don't think so but
you know it's the first year of the
program but unfortunately the ACLU and a
bunch of other plaintiffs just actually
got an injunction against the first
4,000 kids had signed up and so they
can't try out the Nevada education
savings accounts and it's not the first
education savings accounts program I
think right now there's five education
savings account program in the country
and Arizona was actually the first and
they applied it to a certain kind of kid
so if you have special needs your
parents can use your money to customize
and that's a good place to start I think
and now actually there's a huge Indian
population that has been poorly served
in Arizona and our very low scoring
families that have very low performing
schools and so they actually the entire
Indian population has access now in
Arizona to the education savings account
the bottom line I would just say is that
choice is not going away there's one to
two million kids homeschooling there's
you know over two million kids in
charter schools districts have all kinds
of in district choice programs now where
you don't have to go to your residential
assignment school and ask you know
technology makes it easier right now you
can take a full course you know you can
teach yourself almost anything online
you can find someone that has developed
a curriculum and in many cases for free
if you wanted to learn something and
that's definitely going to have an
impact I think on the future of
education but the deficit
right now and what we're really looking
for in the libertarian moment is that we
haven't yet got to the point where
someone has found the uber of Education
or has revolutionized it or Rattle
radical eyes to in some way I mean we're
still kind of we're still spending the
majority of the 600 billion in the same
way that we went to school in the 1970s
when I went to school the same way kids
went to school really for decades so we
are still kind of waiting in education
but the good news is that we have all
this pressure from all sides where
parents really do want to customize and
individualize their kids education